now earlier this week the government
published some details about its plans
for immigration the new system will come
into force at the start of next year and
it aims to reduce low-skilled
immigration to the United Kingdom with
the government saying it wants to see
Brits trained up to do jobs that would
otherwise be done by migrants but
concerns have been expressed by business
groups that the plans could lead to
shortages of staff and knock-on effects
for the economy well one person with
strong views on this is Labour's shadow
home secretary Diane Abbott she joins us
now in the studio thank you for being
with us this morning so what do you make
them make of the government's plans for
integration I think they're completely
misconceived and it's all about looking
as if they're tough on immigration but
they are not actually considering the
underlying needs of the economy and they
also make the mistake of saying that
your salary level tells you tells the
society how valued you are on what your
contribution is to society there are
lots of people who play a very valuable
role who are relatively low paid but the
government should be starting at what
the economy needs and what the society
needs and not playing dog-whistle
politics with immigration when we spoke
to George Eustace about this earlier and
he was effectively saying that Brits can
do some of the jobs some of those know
skilled or low paid jobs that you're
talking about anybody couldn't do any
job but what we're talking about is the
realities of social care in London the
southeast for instance and you were not
going to suddenly replace the EU
migrants were not able to come here and
the people that will suffer them will be
the people that need social care it also
has a knock-on effect on the NHS because
if you're not able to provide good
social care services you get people then
interested unable to discharge this is a
very misconceived policy it's all about
giving the impression of being hawkish
on migration it will also be quite
difficult to come to the UK unless you
speak English I mean many of our views
will think that that is fair enough
what's your view well it's very enough
but actually it's
if the kind of dog was something you
can't function in the British labor
market you don't speak English and
they've put that in to meet and it
should have isn't a real issue
you cannot function the British labor
market without speaking English and of
course people should speak English but
mostly they don't we're of course in the
middle of a labor and leadership
election so policies at the minute are
of a slight it slightly still being
worked on but where do you think labor
should be on immigration should labour
be embracing free movement of people
well I don't know about embracing free
movement of people but I support free
movement and the truth is on the one
hand when we come out of the EU free
movement of such fools but then we're
gonna have very long drawn-out
negotiations about trades and in reality
we're going to have to have a measure of
free movement if we want to have any
access at all to the single market so
freedom of movement is a reality the
problem with the debate it's too many
people usually movement as a euphemism
for immigration in general and that's
not helpful I mean some would say though
that the vote to leave for many people
was a vote for control of borders not
necessarily cutting immigration to
really low levels but just to control
and if there is free movement you don't
have control
well this notion of control again
we shouldn't be starting from that we
should be starting from one of the needs
of the economies our society and so the
tourist immigration policies send a
really unpleasant message about us not
valuing migrants in seeing migrants of
some sort of problem do you think that
Britain's a racist country no I think
the Windrush scandal showed us something
a lot of politicians talking behave as
if British people are answer immigrant
what the Windrush scandal showed us is
actually the majority of British people
value what migrants generations of
markets have done and what they want is
a fair system not an anti migrant system
with this dog-whistle stuff about people
have to be able to speak English I mean
talking about Windrush and according to
the times an early draft of the report
into the home offices handling of that
winter scandal described the department
is institutionally racist now that
since been toned down do you think the
Home Office is institutionally racist I
worked with the Home Office years ago
and I came down from Cambridge and they
had a little youthfulness at the time
about pressure to immigrate countries
and pressure to immigrate countries were
black and brown countries I don't think
that the home office is full of
individual races but I do think they run
a system which is detrimental to black
and brown migrants so would you say that
is institutionally racist well you know
individuals but as an institution
institutional racism is a difficult
phrase I'm not talking about and about
any individuals I'm talking about our
system there's no question and the
Windrush scandal was the best example of
it but there's no question having worked
there and having dealt with thousands of
immigration cases down the years that
the home office runs a system which is
detrimental to black and brown people
okay
and I'm keen to talk to you about the
leadership contest is running on as well
you're backing Rebecca long Bailey what
do you make of the contest so far well I
think all very good candidates let's be
clear I think that the advantage we
would have with Rebecca long bailey is
that she's a great supporter of the
movement I mean when she mean by the
movement the labor movement and when
here and Lisa stood down from the Shadow
Cabinet in an attempt to force Jeremy
Corbyn out
Becky stood by the members choice and
that says something about it I also
think she brings some of the best
characteristics of the other two so for
instance she's a lawyer like here so she
has that very forensic approach to
policy and is very good on detail she
comes from the north of England like
Lisa and therefore she really
understands how people felt many of them
long-standing labor voters that didn't
feel able to support us I'm in the past
and she's also the person that is
constructed one of our most important
and popular policies
the Queen you do so she's the one for me
and I'm interested to talk about how
when you were saying she's supported the
movement are you worried that if Kirsten
will release in handy wins over Rebecca
long Bailey that they'll move away from
Corbin ISM I'm not saying that I am
saying when times were tough and other
people were stepping down from the front
bench Becky stood by the members choices
leader and I think that's important I
mean at least nandi for example when
she's addressed the fact that she stood
down has said that part of the reason
was because she was worried about the
way anti-semitism was investigated so
she would say that standing by and doing
nothing was the wrong thing to do well I
understand her saying that but I was
there at the time and I know why I know
what people like me sitting here said
about standing down but she I don't
wanna talk about the past
but I want to talk about the importance
of loyalty and the importance of the
qualities that Becky will bring to the
leadership with a disloyal at the time I
wouldn't want to say that but I mean
they did step down okay I'm Becky didn't
okay
he's your second preference game too
well
I'm not thinking about a second
preference for me it's Becky okay okay
and now Jeremy Corbyn has said that he
would happily serve in the next leaders
Shadow Cabinet would you well you know I
will be stepping down because I think
that the new leader whether it's Becky
whether it's Lisa whether it's here they
have to be able to construct their own
shadow cabinet and you know I was back
bencher for a few years and there's an
awful lot to do on the back benches one
of the things that I will want to do is
make sure we don't make a swerve to the
rights or migration policy I think
that's the dead end for the Labor Party
we have to stand by our principles stand
by our values and make sure we have an
immigration policy which is fair and
which is workable okay would it be a
shame if labor didn't elect a woman
leader well I've been a campaigning
feminist for 30 years of
cause I would like to see women leader
it's a little bit embarrassing that the
stories have had two women leaders and
we haven't have only never ever had one
so that's part of why I'm supporting
back you're not the most important thing
but it's one of the reasons I'm
supporting back you so do you think it
would be a bit embarrassing if the man
won again I don't think it'll be
embarrassing exactly but you know we are
long over to you a woman leader and I
think Becky is the right choice okay now
I want to talk about the election loss
the worst result for labor since 1935
and why do you think that devastating
was on happened well some of the causes
of our loss particularly the erosion of
our vote in the north and cold field
craters and so on actually predates the
Jeremy Corbyn leadership I mean the
erosion of our supports in some of those
twenties was going on under new labor
but at the same time the erosion that
support they were votes at Tony Blair
won in 1997 he did win but the vote was
eros he and continued to do so this was
all sat very sadly this you can't blame
new labor Shirley for the point I'm
making this was our fourth
failure to win an election on the trot
she can't blame it entirely on the
Corbin leadership it was the Corbin
leadership partly to blame will you
accept that well you know I ran in
Hadley laws and then Hackney know they
love Jeremy Corbyn when I went out to
different parts of the country not
London during the election campaign yeah
his name came up and awful long wait
would because I mean I have never you
know and I've been around people 30
years seen the sort of attack on a
Labour leader that Jeremy Corbyn hatch
it into I mean they're really unpleasant
attack why are you saying voters are
more gullible outside of London then I
don't understand why that would be any
different in happy North or in Dudley
North it's a bit of a night North
because we're next door taking two more
so a lot of them no Jeremy no it was a
it was a very difficult campaign
Jeremy had to withstand terrible attacks
in the media that will cease you've
anti-semitism which people thought
hadn't been dealt with adequately
rightly or wrongly but it was part of a
downturn in the neighborhood vote which
goes in the way back to 2010 some
listening we may think that you just
haven't learned the lessons from that
defeat you're defending Jeremy Corbyn
talk about attacks in the media that you
of course said that when it comes to
brexit labor should have been even more
unequivocally remain during that
referendum and you're talking about new
labor and losses that have been
happening over decades have you really
come to terms with what happened oh I
think I've come to terms I remember
obviously I was up on election night
waiting to hear my own result and the
first results that came through was
Blythe Valley you know and if you've
been listening to general election
results as long as I have and when you
hear we've lost by a solid you know were
in for a horrible night so if it was a
horrible result we have to learn the
lessons we have to select the right
person to leader and that's Becky long
Bailey okay now while you're here I'm
keen to ask about a tweet that you sent
a few weeks ago it has had some
attention in the media and it came after
the former parliamentary official David
leaky accused the former Speaker John
Bercow of bullying and you sent this
tweet which she later deleted the
allegations come from a former
parliamentary official David leaky he's
been a lieutenant general he served in
Germany Northern Ireland and Bosnia but
claims he was bullied ie intimidated and
coerced by John bajo unlikely now
important of course to say John Burke
has denied the bullying allegations but
are you implying in this tweet that it's
unlikely that somebody who was there in
the Army could have been bullying
anybody can be bullets anybody of any
age or any profession can be bullied I
think I can intimidating leaky is one
thing but of course anybody can be both
anyone can be intimidated as well
country anybody can be intimidated but I
think that given leaky and the the
leadership roles that he had played as I
said I think it was unlike he was
intimidated by John Baca annoyed by John
Bercow
insulted by John back out but not
intimidated why don't you think he could
have been intimidated surely anybody can
be abused or believed anybody can be
abused and I know more about this in
some members of parliament because I
remain the most abused online of any
Labour MP but all I was saying that was
even leaked his history seems unlike
he'd actually be intimidated by John
Bercow but I mean someone say the same
if you though like the first black woman
to be elected to Parliament in there
since the 1980s anyone cutter you've
seen the stuff I've got I get on on new
media on Twitter all the time about rape
about violence abuse of course that's
intimidating being intimidated is one
thing but then you have to move forward
and what I've done is moved forward but
don't tell me that I'm supposed to put
up with threats of apps against my
family and threats of rape and daily
abuse online because I don't have to
what I do have to do is to continue to
stand up for the things I believe in and
move forward and that is what I'm doing
absolutely that's why for so many people
you are an inspiration when it comes to
these subjects and looking to you for
how people should respond I think people
should respond by what I think one of
the things that the the media outlets
see online outlets should do is stop
anonymity online you could you can post
under a pseudonym but Twitter Facebook
whoever should actually have your name
and address because when we try and
follow up some of the really abusive
things and threats of violence online we
cannot trace the people because no one
has their name and address so I think
there needs to be an end to anonymity
online that's one of the things that
should happen and I also think that
mainstream media newspapers and
television should reflect on the way
they can sometimes seem like an echo
chamber to the worst abuse online but I
don't want to look back and I don't want
to talk about me I want to look forward
and so we're the Labour Party can go and
what the
the party can do underneath with Becky
Lord Bailey do you think the Labour
Party needs to address some of the
issues that you've just been talking
about there though when it comes to
social media and the what you would
describe is the mainstream media as well
oh I mean yes everyone has to address it
because you know you know why it can
certainly I think we've discussed this
before it concerns me because I think
young women and young men people
thinking of coming into politics will be
put off by the level of abuse that women
politicians of both parties actually and
bein politicians get and I don't want to
see a new generation put off because of
quite unreasonable levels of abuse
online okay Diana Baur thank you so much
for being the studio today much
appreciated